hello and welcome to my basic tutorial
for python 3 on the while loop the while
loop is used to perform an operation
while a condition
is
whatever you set right so the while loop
is very much like the next loop the for
loop uh and they're interchangeable
uh so it really just comes down to
personal preference
uh so let's go ahead and show an example
so now what i want to say is let's just
say to make things you know super simple
we'll say condition
equals one so we're a condition is a
variable and we're assigning the value
of one to the condition
uh the next thing we're going to say is
wow
condition
is less than 10 so we're actually using
something called an assignment operator
we will talk a little bit more on those
uh
in probably a couple videos but for now
this should make total sense to you you
should be able to read this and be like
okay that makes sense
um so while the condition is less than
10 what do we want to do
well for now let's just print
whatever the condition is and now we're
now we're going to use another uh thing
that i was trying to show you guys
earlier but for whatever reason it
yelled at me and we're going to do
condition
plus
equals one and what plus equals does is
it takes that variable and adds one to
it so plus equals you might be thinking
well why didn't you just do condition
plus one why not that well the reason
why you don't do that is condition plus
one will just yield a value but it won't
actually assign
that value to anything so condition plus
equals one is really the only thing
that's equal to can or would do the same
operation as plus equals would be
condition equals
condition
plus 1. now as you can see uh this is a
much shorter way to do that
but that this is what it's doing it's
just taking the previous value and
adding one to it
so we'll do that so while it's less than
ten it's going to add one to it and then
obviously eventually it's going to get
to the point where it's no longer less
than 10 and this while loop will stop or
break so let's save and run that one
and as we can see we ran all the way
through one two three four five seven
eight nine and stop
so as you can see when it did become 10
it didn't run because 10 is not less
than 10.
so
um so that's one of the neat things you
can do now the other thing uh probably
the most common use for me
uh with the while loop is the following
so um i actually prefer the next loop
that i'll be showing you guys more but
wow does have a nice little thing for it
and that is called the wow true loop
and what's nice about this is it makes
what's known as an infinite loop now
sometimes
the infinite loop
is
something that you don't want but other
times the infinite loop is something you
do want so in order to make your own
little infinite loop you can do while
true and true basically
uh means this will always run because
while true is true it runs and it's just
like this like so when you look at wow
it's almost like an if statement is
being thrown in here and i'll teach you
guys about if statements soon but
condition less than 10 basically it's
asking is that true or false is that
true or false every time through and as
soon as it's false it stops running so
that's why when you just throw true in
here true is like a
boolean so to speak in programming terms
uh and it's like you know zero or one
and so you can use true and it'll do
stuff now i haven't showed you guys the
time module yet so this is really gonna
go quite crazy it's gonna print doing
stuff as fast as it can so
i will warn you guys beforehand i'm sure
some of you guys have already run the
script out of it just sheer excitement
and now you're probably like oh my gosh
what do i do well what you gonna do at
this point is to break
this infinite loop or any running script
you can do control hold ctrl and press c
and that will break the script so let's
go ahead and run this bad boy so we'll
run it save it run it boom and it's just
like going crazy printing stuff right
it's just
so to break it ctrl
c and it might take a second because i
let it go for a while so it probably has
quite the cue uh
yes it is going for a while i shouldn't
have talked so much
there it goes finally man
anyway
so if it doesn't happen initially uh for
you it's just because it had so many you
know that it got behind because the this
little console here is pretty slow if
you did the same thing like in an actual
you know you executed the script uh
control c usually is is instantaneous
pretty much
so anyways that's the wow loop hopefully
you guys understand uh the idea here
um
and in the next tutorial what we're
going to cover is the for loop typically
uh the while loop is most used as a form
of counter right so it's just it's there
to count something uh that's where i
honestly see it used the most but
actually the for loop and the while loop
uh can be completely interchangeable so
the while loop can do what a for loop
does
and
a for loop can do what a while loop does
it just comes down to preference i tend
to like the for loop better but it
really doesn't matter so anyway that's
what we're gonna be doing in the next
video is the four
loop
uh hopefully you guys learned something
new hopefully you guys are enjoying the
tutorials as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions
and until next time